une sortie du marché unique européen au
soir du 31 décembre sans accord de
libre-échange semble désormais l'issue
la plus probable
hier dans la soirée le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson s'est
entretenu avec la présidente de la
commission européenne
ursula von der leyen à l'issue de la
conversation téléphonique
les divergences se sont confirmées pour
l'ombre le temps disponible et très
brefs et il semble désormais très
probable qu'un accord ne puisse pas être
atteints sans changement significatif de
la position de l'union européenne
pourtant plus tôt dans la journée d'hier
michel barnier avait évoqué de bons
progrès à l'issue d'une conférence avec
les eurodéputés
mais à l'issue de son entretien avec
boris johnson ursula von der leyen ne
partageaient pas le même optimisme
avec boris johnson nous avons fait le
point sur les négociations entre lieux
et le royaume uni nous avons salué des
progrès importants sur de nombreux
sujets cependant de grosses divergences
subsistent en particulier sur la pêche
les combles et sera très difficile les
négociations continueront demain le 31
décembre le royaume uni quittera
définitivement le marché unique et
l'union douanière en l'absence d'accord
les seules règles de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce s'appliquerait
l'entrée en vigueur des droits de douane
et des quotas pourraient alors avoir de
lourdes conséquences sur des économies
déjà très fragilisée par l'épidémie de
kovy de 19